[Music]
n
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him blood poisoning that's what he said
blood poisoning Grant Paul
Hitler that is my new nickname for him
Grant Paul
Hitler what the [__] you want from me
what am I supposed to do guy's talking
about being dictator guy want wants to
talk about blood poisoning I mean words
Straight Out of Mind com I don't know if
you know that it's kind of funny that um
Donnie dict
taster is wanting to emulate the little
mustache man which shouldn't be
surprising this is what the fash do they
are not creative do not have new
ideas they just copy and paste from the
last murderish regime
now I don't know if you know what minec
means in German what minec means in
German is my struggle that's what it
means it was basically a whiny little
[__]
Fest from a prison cell it's what it
was Adolf Hitler tried to do a
coup of the German government he
failed it was criminal they put him in
prison and he wrote a book book about
his victimhood I mean it's written not
in German but in
victim so should we see be surprised
that these whiny little [__] on the
right here in this country are standing
on
stage reading
directly from
MC that whiny little [__] of a book are
we surp are we are we supposed to be
surprised by this I'm not [__]
surprised by this I've seen this coming
for a long [__] time
I've been calling these people niot
Nazis for over three goddamn years I've
been calling them niot Nazis three years
I've been on this pounding the
drum saying saying hello hello think
McFly
think this is not hard to see where this
was
going as they tried to
demonize people coming across the border
who are brown as they demonized people
of other religion
as they demonized the lgbtq committee
and trans people trans children now
parents of trans
children women trying to strip away
their [__] rights to health care and
criminalizing being pregnant that's
right they're [__] criminalizing
being
pregnant all the while these little
fascists are having the little fascia
palas the turning points USA event
telling young women in this country
don't get educated
don't be
independent have as many babies as you
can afford I'm not [__] kidding you
they said that [__] out loud on
stage everyone um is trying to pay
attention to the blood poisoning thing
which we should pay attention but that's
not the first time he said that
[__] it's not the it's not the last time
he'll say that [__]
either hello world it is December 18th
Monday and you know what happens Monday
through Friday the Tony Michaels podcast
for two full [__] hours good news
great news I am Unchained and unbanned
everywhere that's right
Unchained and
unbanned
[Laughter]
everywhere no one and nothing can stop
me now
I want to thank everyone uh who came
last night uh to the Christmas karaoke I
appreciate all of you joining in it was
so much fun it really was it was such a
great time uh last night that I had with
you on Christmas karaoke if you guys
want to go watch it you can watch it on
the twitch Channel that's right you can
watch it on the twitch Channel let me
show you how to get to it you just go to
the Tony michaels.com let me show you
here look at the Christmas background we
got going on it's Christmas week so I
you might we might as well show these
right Wingers that we love Christmas man
Merry Christmas that we're not scared to
say Merry Christmas we don't think it's
offensive to say Merry Christmas we just
think it's offensive when you don't want
to acknowledge all the other holidays
it's kind of weird that you're such an
[__] H I wonder what it could be
could it be that you're just an [__]
wherever you can be
but I digress let's show you where today
today's current episode is right here as
always and then the patreon Christmas
karaoke's here it takes you to the
twitch Channel you guys can watch there
if you want to throw some money in the
tip jar you can still do that the
karaoke tip jar is here I won't be
taking requests though I mean I guess I
could take some requests and you guys
could you know come see me live and in
person at karaoke That's this Wednesday
or you can buy me a shot you can send me
a vinmo Super Chat I'll bring it up on
screen or if you swear like I do you can
put some money in the swear jar but a
great way to support the Tony Michaels
podcast is on patreon that's right on
patreon and a few of our members of the
patreon joined us last night for
Christmas karaoke and I want to thank uh
Kim I want to thank Erica and I I want
to thank een and Kim and Eileen sang for
us last night Erica had hung out and
chatted with us so I appreciate all you
guys showing up on camera and coming and
hanging out with me on camera for
everyone to see it's so fun to hang out
with you guys and and do that um special
kind of thing on patreon so go join the
patreon you can join for free if you
want to support the show monetarily you
can do that any membership you buy you
can get 10% off if you pay for the full
year a lot of people have been doing
that so I appreciate all your support if
you're supporting me over on patreon
also don't forget we got the book club
going on right now at the Discord
sponsored by the library of democracy
win every argument by many assign is
what they're reading now and they're
still listening to Rachel mano's book
over there the audio version so go join
the Discord and the book club the link
is right here you just click in here
it'll make you join the Discord don't
worry about it don't worry about the
Discord you just click the green check
mark you can participate in all the
other Discord stuff or just the book
club and I want to thank everyone over
this last week who has followed me over
to
Twitch it's been great having you guys
over on another platform and I
appreciate all the people who support me
there on Twitch by linking their Amazon
Prime account to their Twitch account I
think we converted a few people too to
Twitch some people like twitch better
some people hate twitch some people like
Facebook some people hate Facebook some
people love the YouTube Some people
[__] hate it well there's a new place
we're broadcasting from we're going to
try it out Instagram I have no idea how
it works I don't know I don't even think
I can see the comments so if you're
typing in comments over there especially
if you're a troll I'm not going to see
them over there so if you want me to see
your trolling comments you're going to
want to come to Facebook YouTube or
twitch if you're trying to yell and
scream and tell me how ridiculous I am
and what a libtard I am then you're
gonna want to go to those other
platforms I just can't see you on
Instagram
sorry sorry sorry it's not going to
happen oh boy ho boy boy was there a lot
of stuff happen over the weekend now I
have to
say I told you
so it wasn't that hard though to predict
this it really
wasn't it wasn't that hard to predict
this when Donnie dict taster said out
loud in front of a microphone that he
may want to be dictator for a day I told
you the very next day the very next day
I told you that they would the Sheep
would be standing in line at a Nazi
rally a trump Nazi rally and they would
say that they wanted him to be dictator
that that's what they wanted because
that's truly what they want that's what
he wants to he wants them to want him to
be a dictator they want him to be a
dictator like it's all right there it's
all right there in front of your face
you can see everything and why the media
is so surprised by this is [__]
Beyond me I mean listen MSNBC produc ERS
who watch this show you should not be
surprised but and stop tell stop getting
your host to act surprised stop doing
that stop it I've been telling you this
[__] for [__] months and years and I
also predicted as soon as he said I want
to be a dictator that his people his
sheep his cult would be like yeah we
want him to be a dictator literally I
have a clip of it it's a thing that
happened not only are they not not
saying the Qui part out loud they're
[__] raising their I'm not [__]
you they're raising their
hands raising I don't know if you know
what this means in history when you're
raising your hand for a dict I don't
know if you know the symbolism of that
but that's what they're
doing oh my [__] God these [__]
people but I'm not surprised by this you
shouldn't be surprised by this I told
you this was going to happen it's a
[__] cult folks it's a [__] cult
and he lets them and gives them
permission to be the worst [__]
version of themselves and these are the
worst of the worst of
us some people are asking are you
serious you goddamn right I'm serious
I'm telling you I'm gonna show you the
[__] clip I told you this what
happened I told you I told you just
[__] doubt me just [__] doubt keep
doubting me MSNBC producers that are
listening just keep [__] doubting me
honestly just stop listening to the show
you guys can email me you can get a hold
of me I know you probably have
memberships on my website or some [__]
just [__] DM me and I'll give you the
skinny on how it's going to work I'll
tell you I'll I'll give you the Insight
look Donald Trump is going to say it's
gonna get much worse F folks much much
worse this is not the worst of the
rhetoric this blood poisoning and I want
to be a dictator for a day and then them
clamoring over it so much so that
they're raising their hands to salute to
fear her and support of the fear her
it's going to get much worse now I want
to be optimistic about this it's going
to get much worse in the rhetoric and
it's going to get much worse for
them this is not what the American
society's fabric is about the fabric of
our society is not about
authoritarianism about
dictatorship about finding the perfect
dictators so that we can worship them
that's not what the American fabric is
it never has been it's actually the
[__] opposite
that's the whole [__] point of the
Constitution it was the whole [__]
point of a revolution and a
revolutionary war it's the whole
[__] Point okay and I know that
sometimes in our country things get lost
right things get lost we we lose certain
parts of our our sentiment right as
Society moves on and we get bigger and
bigger and and we we appropriate more
culture into our country and we grow we
become more diverse we kind of lose some
of these little aspects but I don't know
if you noticed a lot of our main
institutions that this country was built
on like ah white rich land
owners
men I don't know if you noticed but a
lot of that has stayed as the [__]
Foundation I don't know if you
noticed but oppressing brown and black
people in this country has kind of
stayed around kind of stuck around for a
while I don't know if you noticed that
but it's true it's
here and there are really shitty gross
parts of our history and parts of our
fabric that we should try to undo as
Society like the oppression of people
because of their religion or the color
of their skin or who they are we should
stop that nonsense we should work for
diversity and Equity inclusion and
liberty for all people no matter who you
are as long as you're in this country
and really around the world but this
country is the one we have control over
we have the vote it is us we the people
who are the governing
body as long as we have control over it
we should do that it takes a while to
undo American fabric of
society that's what's working against
them okay that's what's working against
I don't know if you remember uh there
was a pandemic in 2020 I don't know if
you're around or you know you got wind
of
this there's this idea in this country
and and we really had to fight against
our own American type feeling that you
can't tell us what the [__] to do you
don't get to tell us what to do we're
American right and it was the mask that
was kind of at the center of this and
they're still bitching and moaning about
the mask as if anyone's forcing anyone
or ever did really Force anyone toar a
mask you could have just stayed the [__]
at home you didn't have to wear a mask
you could have just stayed the [__] at
home the same way thing with the vacine
right they did the same [__] you can't
force this our body our choice oh really
huh seems kind of funny but that really
is the American sentiment that is the
fabric of our country that we are
independent Jesus Christ we have fought
war after war after War for this ideal
and somehow they think the right thinks
because they move more and more and more
and more to the fash and more to the
right and more to be murderous dictators
are salivating over murderous dictators
they think that's going to play well in
the populace get the [__] out of here
these are not populist messages folks
they're
not you know what is populist
message earning a decent [__]
wage not going broke because of a
medical bill not having your [__]
rights to Health Care Stripped Away from
you because a bunch of old wrinkly ball
sacks don't understand healthare
procedures not criminalizing being
pregnant huh huh that's kind of a
populous message folks there's a new
kind of liberalism on the horizon here
it really is on the horizon and that's
the optimism that I want to give you
because whenever you are whenever you
are confronted with a choice
there is a choice you have a choice you
get a choice you can do this or you can
do that and when you see something and
you're like whoa that [__] sucks
that's horrible that's terrible I would
never want that so I'm going to choose
the other
thing that's also deep within our
American
fabric we don't generally support things
we are against things
I know you know have you been on Twitter
lately have you been on social media on
Facebook
lately people are against [__] loudly
and proudly they are [__] against
it's America Goddamn it you can't do
that here you sons of [__] that's the
[__] fabric of our country that's why
I'm so optimistic that's why I know that
all let's go Brandon has to do dark
Brandon has to do is get up in the
morning put his [__] shoes on and do
his job that's all he's got to do that's
all Brandon has to do that's all he has
to do and he's been doing it day after
day after day after
day and just let America see the choice
that they have okay we you GNA choose
between a guy who's getting off on stage
talking about mine comp type [__]
wanting to take our [__] rights away
wanting to send people off the camps
give give military generals the death
penalty
what what talking about our religion and
[__] our our religion what the [__] are
you talking about or we can have the guy
that has a steady
hand he's ready to do his
job he's getting up every morning and
thinking about America and
America a different better America more
diverse more Equitable more inclusive
with more Liberty more freedoms and more
rights on the
horizon and he wants to give the power
to the American people to do
that well let's go [__]
Brandon are we gonna take that phrase
away from them or what this year that's
what I think we should do is take that
stupid [__] phrase back from them
let's go Brandon [__] yeah let's do that
[__] because the other [__] guy the
other [__] guy Grandpa [__] Hitler
are you [__] kidding me that's what
the [__] you want I don't think so no
[__] way is this country gonna choose
Grandpa Hitler the Republican party
is the Republican party is going to
choose Grandpa Hitler it is going to
happen you just [__] sit back and
doubt me do whatever you want you you
can choose to have cognitive dissonance
you can choose to ignore what I'm trying
to tell you is the [__] truth you can
do that all you want but the truth don't
give a [__] and the reality doesn't give
a [__] about what you believe or don't
believe what you're offended by or not
offended by whether you like that I cuss
or don't I don't give a
[__] I'm going to tell you the [__]
truth the way that I see it and I'm
going to tell you what is coming whether
you like it or
not that's what I'm here for and that's
why you're here you're not supposed to
agree with me on every single aspect of
this okay that's not how it's supposed
to work it's actually you're supposed to
disagree with me on [__] you're supposed
descent that's the whole [__] idea of
democracy in the first place okay that's
how you progress a democracy
anyways and it's time to descent okay
and it's time to descent against people
who want to try to save the Republican
party that's right I said it and more
and more people are coming coming over
to our side of the new brand of
liberalism folks oh my god did you see
that a bunch of lefties in this country
the same people people who love Osama
Bin Laden and Hamas propaganda oh man
they're so mad at John
fedman
good
good cast yourself out of the
pro-democracy Coalition let us know who
you
are let us know who you are because you
[__] you [__] Theocratic fascist
sympathizers are not going to be welcome
in the pro-democracy
Coalition you [__] [__] like Paul
Ryan Liz cheny minger who think they can
say the Republican party you are not
welcome in the Pro democracy
Coalition now a lot of people are going
to get mad at me and they're gonna be
like Tony we need them to
win I get that you think that that's
that's the reality but it's not the
reality we do not need them in our
coalition to win we don't need them in
our coalition to win their goals are
completely different than our
goals our goals is to save democracy to
prop up the institutions of
democracy to make liberal democracy The
Shining City on the [__] Hill that it
deserves to
be where freedoms and rights are the
vehicle to our
Liberty that is the founding principles
of liberal democracy and that is what we
should stand on and that is the prism we
should look through no matter what
commentary no matter what narrative or
what policy we are talking about
no matter
what and just because we don't welcome
them into our Coalition doesn't mean
that their fight isn't going to help our
fight there are parallel battles going
on in our country and inside the
ideological
World okay there's parallel
battles our battle is for our new brand
of liberalism our new
ideology and it truly is the Bedrock of
our Democratic constitutional
republic it is the
Bedrock the foundation of it and anyone
who wants their goal to be to save the
Republican party you can have that fight
Paul Ryan Liz Cheney Adam kininger Chris
Christie Mitt Romney Ken Buck all the
rest of them can go fight that war and
that battle let
them
their means works out for our ends do
you see do you see how it works their
means justifies our ends so let them
have that fight let the lefties who love
Osama Bin Laden who love who love Hamas
propaganda and who hate that John fedman
says something about Progressive or
doesn't say something about Progressive
because they don't understand
Pennsylvania politics well it is
clear it is clear that there is a new
ideology there is a new brand of
liberalism coming to the Forefront and
they're terrified of it the
authoritarians in this country whether
they're on the right or the left are
terrified of this new brand of
liberalism and the reason why is because
they're not going to bully us they're
not going to bully John fedman are you
[__] kidding me you think you think
cuz John fedman is getting heat from the
old Bernie Bros and the and the extreme
radical left because he said I'm not a
progressive and he has a reasonable
stance about immigration whether you
agree with it or not you think that's
going to make him change his ideology
and know how to win elections in
Pennsylvania well you got another
[__] come thing coming you are you
are dumber than dog [__] frankly dog
turds are jealous of how stupid you are
and really honestly you're starting to
sound like
manga you're starting to sound like
manga honestly it's really [__] dumb
anyone who dissents from from maa's
ideology is out on their ass out on
their ass they kick them out they're not
part of the Republican party you know
because they're not Nazi enough well
we're GNA try to do that with John
fedman get the [__] out of here with
that [__] the pro democracy Coalition
should tell John vetman don't worry bro
we got your [__] back
that is the new brand of liberalism
folks that is the winning
narrative that is how we [__] win for
Liberty in this
country that is how we make sure we put
our country back on track and think more
about our Constitution and how those
rights and freedoms that are granted by
that Constitution Deliver us our
Liberty and it's time we put a little
bit of Common Sense back in this [__]
and really honestly I'm glad that some
of these people on the left have exposed
how ridiculous they [__] are because
they're not going to go vote for Trump
you know every people like Tony you're
gonna isolate I'm I'm gonna isolate
people what the [__] what do you I
didn't do this I didn't go and say John
fedman is a [__] he's a republican
because he he he he has to win an
election in Pennsylvania get the [__]
out of here with that [__] you are a
dumb [__] you are a dumb mother
[__] you don't understand politics you
need to stop with the [__] and
honestly any commentator out there
saying this stupid [__] and the rational
National was one of them I listened to
his video about John fedman the rational
National he's a Canadian by the way
which I have nothing against Canadians
and Canadians should absolutely have
opinions on American politics but hey
hey Dole I think his name is Dale Dole I
think this dumb motherfucker's name is
with the rational National hey buddy hey
buddy listen listen before you form your
stupid [__] commentary you really
need to think hard about why John fedman
is saying what he's saying and why he's
doing what he's
doing then maybe you can form commentary
that is worth a [__] and frankly
honestly the more people that stop
watching this [__] trash out there
especially these trashy [__] on
the left I mean we we don't listen we
don't listen to that trashy [__] on the
right I know you people don't [__] I
don't listen to it I got to go watch the
clips just so and show you what the hell
they're saying right and I goddamn for
sure don't want to have to start showing
you clips from the left because they're
[__]
ridiculous but I'll do it if I [__]
have to for democracy I'll do it you you
know I'm not going to [__] around and
and and not point out people who are
damaging our [__] democracy and who
are who are trying to to trying trying
to take our
Coalition the liberal Coalition look
look the lefties they [__] hate
liberals the rational National he
[__] hates
liberals David Dole is his name yeah I
don't know [__] what what am I supposed
to David Dole it's apparently his name
[__] David Dole and the rational
National you should turn that [__] the
[__] off and tell other people to turn
that [__] [__] off it's trash
it's all for clicks and
Views and anyone out there saying [__]
for clicks and Views and trying to
[__] please Their audience trying to
say the [__] that their that Their
audience is going to like and want to
hear then they're full of [__] [__]
rather they're way on the left or
they're trying to emulate the [__]
mainstream media it ain't GNA happen
here I believe in the audience I believe
in the American people I believe in
them I have that American optimism about
our country and about our democracy it
is
there and it is strong you don't have to
[__] bash
it especially especially Bash one of the
strongest [__]
Brands one of the strongest [__]
brands in liberalism
today and it's coming it's coming folks
and they can't stop it because I'm not
going to shut the [__]
up I'm not going to shut the [__] up it
ain't going to happen every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific except for
the next few weeks because we got
holidays coming up so the next three
weeks are three- day weeks but we'll be
back on track after the holidays don't
worry and don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 Seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizza's come fast knock knock who's
there pizza magic eat pepperoni hug spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's like
family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast oh oh we wish you a Merry
Christmas we wish you a Merry
[Applause]
Christmas was anyone offended that I
sing Christmas music you think the
Wright was pissed off they were mad
about the first ladyes little video she
made of the Nutcracker in the White
House oh man they were real upset that
Joe Biden made a Christmas video this is
the war on Chris it doesn't make any
sense of course it doesn't make any
sense
of course it doesn't make any
sense a lot of people are wondering who
um who I referring to this um David Dole
he's got a YouTube channel it's called
the rational
National he's been on for a long time
he's got a [__] ton of subscribers and
he he shovels out [__] every day on his
channel that's just not the correct
messaging it's not the narrative that
the left needs it's absolute
garbage it's absolute garbage
I don't have to tell you I mean you know
a lot of people when I first started
speaking out against tyt they were like
Tony you're attacking the
left and then they went and listened to
it and they're like oh my God you're
right tyt is [__]
trash it's
garbage and then they got mad that I
attacked David Pacman for being boring
and they went and listen to Pacman and
they're like yeah he's kind of boring
what do you want from me just telling
you the [__] truth I mean if you
don't like it fine but you know it's
it's just the way I'm I'm just telling
you how it
is because that ain't the kind of [__]
you're going to get here is boring ass
dry commentary commentary that's been
regurgitated from the mainstream media
because it's
safe trying to pretend to be mainstream
when you're trying to be independent all
at the same time trying to have some you
know great take on something yet you
[__] look back backwards on your
takes so [__] out of here yeah you can
like Pacman it's okay Kelly I'm not I'm
not saying you shouldn't like Pacman
Kelly let me see if I can find this
Kelly says here on YouTube we're back on
YouTube by the way says I like Pacman
that's fine you can like him that's
that's fine that's fine you can like him
but he's boring you got to ADM he's
[__]
[Laughter]
boring his commentary is boring his [__]
and he's about three days behind because
he's got to be safe he's got to be safe
he's got to be safe what [__] being safe
this is not the time to be
safe Mr uh can Canada Canadian says tyt
keeps signing polls that's because
they're
[__] any anyone anyone signing any poll
at this point are talking about data or
any of that [__] is full of [__] they're
full of [__] and they're trying to get
you to believe something that you want
to believe or they think you want to
believe are they're trying to push a
narrative that is just not the narrative
that needs to be
pushed Carrie says tyt sucks ass well
I'm not I'm not gonna say they suck ass
but they they do suck they do suck kayn
berson says [__] tyt
[Laughter]
see oh boy um see this is the thing if
in commentary and in media you can you
have you have a couple different choices
like I have a choice every day turning
on this
microphone like I can say the stuff to
attract a certain audience right like I
can say something to attract a certain
audience and then once I have that
certain audience now I have to keep
saying the [__] that they want me to say
no matter if I believe it or not right
because that's the audience that I built
that's not the audience that I want
that's not the audience that's not not
the goal of the show The goal of the
show is to just say what needs to be
said out [__] loud because it's time
that the left and people understand that
Liberals are the strength of democracy
and it's G to take someone just saying
that [__] out loud over and over and
over every [__] day time and time
again never stopping never quitting no
matter how much their voice goes away no
matter how congested they sound or if
they lose their voice or if they're
coughing a
bit it does not matter you have to keep
pounding that [__]
drum it's how it works you can't do one
show a week or two shows a week or have
have 20 shows that do one show a week or
do a few internet [__] social media
videos that ain't going to be
enough it just
ain't it ain't going to be
enough you have to really [__] you
have to really really really work if you
want messaging and narrative to get out
there and it's better to do it with the
truth right and it's better to do it
tethered to reality then trying to
[__] sell some message that isn't
Tethered to reality um Sarah says here
Johnson uh sort of have concern about
Lincoln project too I mentioned that the
other day a lot of people got mad that I
pointed out hey look look they're trying
to welcome Paul Ryan into the
pro-democracy Coalition via Lincoln
project that's
concerning Paul Ryan does not get to be
part of the pro-democracy Coalition he
ruined that a long time ago [__] Paul
Ryan he's not pro-democracy he's not so
he's not he's not going to be get to be
part of the Coalition that's trying to
save democracy
he wants to sa the Republican Party
folks you can hear it in their
voice and it is concerning that a group
who does so much for democracy like
Lincoln project starts to make room now
we don't need to make room for Liz
Cheney and Paul Ryan in the Coalition
they don't get to be in the Coalition
they are not for democracy they are for
Republican party first first and
only okay they they sound like we sound
right now because their goal is to save
the Republican
party but just because they're saying
the [__] that we're saying that Trump is
[__] dangerous he wants to be a
dictator just because they're saying the
truth doesn't mean the truth is that
they're not that they're for it doesn't
mean that we have to welcome them into
our Coalition we don't they can fight
their fight against Trump and we can
fight our fight for
democracy and we can help each other but
we don't we don't have to act like their
for for our
values that they're liberals because
they're not they're not liberals they
never have been never [__] will be
they hate liberalism they [__] hate
it in their bones Paul Ryan and [__]
Liz Cheney and Adam kininger and Mitt
Romney and Chris Christie they [__]
hate liberalism in their [__]
bones tyt hates liberalism hates it the
rational National I'm going to attack
him now he hates [__] liberalism he
[__] hates it he vowed to
Prim he vowed to
primary John fedman in Pennsylvania he
did personally he said I'm gonna do
everything I can
do dude listen man I don't mean to
[__] upset your commentary but your
your [__] commentary isn't it
shouldn't be designed if you really
believe in democracy which you clearly
don't your your commentary should not be
designed and aimed at every single
little individual that you want to take
out you guys noticed that I don't
endorse
candidates have you ever guys have you
guys ever noticed that I've got a lot of
people that send me messages like oh you
should have this candidate on you should
have this candidate which I'm not scared
to have politicians or candidates on I'm
just not gonna endorse
anybody I don't endorse John vetman I'm
not officially endorsing John vetman I'm
not I'm not if there was better if there
was a better candidate that could beat
John fedman in a primary that was better
for democracy I would say hey that one
looks better than John fedman but there
there's probably not going to be in
[__]
Pennsylvania or one that can win with
the way the Pennsylvania politics are
and if you're not aware of that well
then you're just a [__]
bonehead that's like that's like people
complaining to primary this Democrat or
that Democrat because their views don't
exactly align with their ideology well
[__]
me [__] [__] me running listen we got to
get our [__] heads on street we got a
lot of [__] work to do we got a lot
of [__] work to
do and and some of that work is going to
be getting some of these people in this
country pointing them out to everyone to
make sure they understand how ridiculous
they are because folks we are not going
to win this election with a bunch of
[__] U people who think John fedman
isn't good for
democracy what those people are not
goingon to help us just like Liz Cheney
ain't gonna help us okay it's not gonna
happen and when we come to reality with
that we will build a coalition that is
way stronger and will box out the
[__] extremes on the right and the
left I'm telling you I'm very confident
in it I'm telling you I'm telling you
I'm telling you I'm telling you trust me
on this it is how [__] our democracy
works it is how ideology Works in this
country I I know most people don't
understand ideology that's the problem
that we really have that's what we're s
ing from but it is true it is true just
like you shouldn't doubt me when I said
hey the Sheep are going to be standing
in line and they're going to say they
want to fear
her and they did
it of course they did why wouldn't they
are you kidding me why wouldn't they
want a dictator this is what they've
wanted for years and years and years and
years they've wanted a dictator
they've always wanted
it they've always wanted someone to tell
us what they want us to
do right because that's really the goal
it's rules for thee not for me it's what
it
is and it'll continue to be that way
rules for thee not for me because that's
what they want to
do they they want to set rules and
standards like they want to ostracize
lgbtq members of society yet they want
to have [__] threesoms at their
little moms for Liberty their Min
[__] rules for thee not for me but
that's why they want a [__] dictator
it's because they want the dictator to
tell us that we can't do [__] that they
want to
do and they want a dictator so so
[__] bad and I know they do I know
they do the cult wants it so goddamn bad
and it's [__] obvious it's been
obvious for a long goddamn time that's
why they're that's why I call them ning
capop Nazis ning capop Nazis Hitler
would be really disappointed in these
[__] idiots he really Hitler would be
so disappointed in
manga I mean
honestly I mean I'm sure Hitler's just
rolling in his grave in hell did you
know in hell they actually um 10 times a
day they stick pineapples up Hitler's
ass did you know that I I I don't know
if that's a really punishment for Hitler
apparently he was kind of in the closet
like most Republicans and fascists are
but that is apparently I that that's
what people say I've just heard this
that's what they knew in held of Hitler
but you know you know he's highly
disappointed in these folks right but
this weekend he's getting more and more
excited Hitler in his grave in Hell
while he's getting that fourth pineapple
shoved up his ass and it's the wrong way
you know what I mean it's not the right
way not the way that would
feel I mean that would hurt like hell
wouldn't
it
anyways Hitler is getting more and more
excited and he is he is really seeing
that the ninga poops here are doing what
they're supposed to be doing because
Donald Trump is repeating lines from
MC he's like yeah my struggle my
struggle my struggle my struggle my
struggle like line by line by line by
line and he's like I want to be dictator
my name is Grand paaul Hitler I approve
this message right he didn't really talk
like that but that's why you know what I
think if Trump wanted to um actually
attract more cult members he would start
talking like that don't you think look
I'm just telling you I want to be a
dictator
I'm Grandpa Hitler and I prove this
message right that would be Al would
talk this message would really resonate
with these people better I think just
saying Valerie brings up um on Facebook
says movie Little Nikki yeah that's
where I stole that from you guys are
like Tony you're stealing you're
stealing what do you want me to do I
mean I've seen it on I've seen the the
image of it of Hitler getting the
pineapple stuck up his ass on the movie
Little Nikki so you know that's what my
brain thinks that is happening in hell
to Hitler I think it's a good idea don't
you I mean hell when we get rid of
Grandpa Hitler and the guy takes a dirt
nap don't you hope in Hell there him and
Hitler's pineapple times their pineapple
appointments are backto back don't you
hope you know maybe it's a good time to
have pineapple Partners in hell I don't
know could be
anyways um as I said Donnie dict taster
Grandpa Hitler here um he loves talking
about being a dictator and I told you
you can see here in this video that this
interview's got a
microphone and there's a bunch of
chuckleheads standing around here bunch
of [__] chuckle [__] mangas sheep in
the pin I'm not kidding you it's there
there's a fence here and it's the sheep
in the pen in the Sheep
pin and um they're going to say that
they want a dictator now the crazy part
is in this clip oh baby I don't know if
they got the memo or not but really when
you're salivating over a dictator um
there's a certain part of symbolism that
you really don't want to you know let
out of the bag right like there's the
quiet part out loud that these people
are saying they want a dictator because
that's I'm going to give it away that's
what they say in this clip but watch
what they do when this guy ask them to
raise their [__] hand I'm not
[__] you this [__] asks them
to raise their hands of who wants Trump
to be the fearer I'm not kidding you
watch this [__] that's why I have no
problem with day one dictator that's why
I have no problem with it if a dictator
means he's going to drill baby drill
I'll sign me up that dictatorship
anywhere that's why I have no problem
with day one dictator that's why I have
no problem with it it's the wrong clip
it's a wrong clip but but that clip
shows you that they that they they want
a dictator now here's the right clip let
me get to this one here's the one where
they rais their [__] hands okay here
it is watch it hey here's a better
question for everybody here how many
people would be willing to let to have
Donald Trump deputize them when he
becomes president to help them find
every single illegal that's in this
country how many people would raise
their hand for that look at this guy
look at guy look at this guy yeah raise
your hand point it in the air really get
it out there yeah I mean don't they know
when you're when you're when you're
[__] salivating over a dictator the
last piece of symbolism you want is this
do they not understand that do they not
get it do they not oh that's right they
do they do know
it they do know
it they're hiling grantpa Hitler here
they're salivating for a
dictator your hand for that would you
raise your hand would you allow yourself
to be deputized to go find the illegals
in your community it's the only way
we're going to get them all out right he
said he promised massive deportation
mission right he's not going to be able
to do that alone he's not going to be
able to do that with just I think he
needs the American people's help get
your asses out of our country and get
out now you want to come in the right
way we'll welcome you in but until oh
yeah you come in the right way the white
way is what he meant the white way there
you go what do you what do you want from
me I just I just [__] show you this
[__] I'm not I'm not the one I'm not the
one doing
it I'm just showing you what they're
doing that's all I'm doing and it's not
that difficult to show you what they're
doing I've been seeing this writing on
the wall for a long
time and I told you they were going to
stand and say yeah we want a DI dictator
you godamn right we want a dictator I
told you that I told you that a couple
weeks ago whenever the hell it was that
he said he wants to be a dictator and
here it is that's why I have no problem
with day one dictator that's why I have
no problem with it if a dictator means
he's going to drill baby drill I'll sign
me up for that dictatorship anywhere
sign me up for that
dictatorship listen here's the fact I
don't I don't know if these [__]
idiots go look at oil production numbers
they probably don't but we are actually
drilling more oil and there's more oil
production right now in this country
than there was under
Trump it's one of the reasons why
gasoline is going down it's one of the
reasons is because we're actually
drilling more oil under
Brandon than we were under Grandpa
Hitler okay it really is um you know
again I
I try I I try not to show you guys
graphs and [__] you know drop all
kinds of [__] stats and [__] but that
isn't me dropping stance it's just me
telling you the truth go look it up you
can go find it you can go find the oil
production of our country compare it to
now to 2020 and before and you'll know
that our production of oil in this
country has never been
higher we are drill baby drilling that's
what we're doing and we're actually
producing more oil in this country and
we're Drilling in less places that we
should be drilling in and what I mean by
that is places that we can't take back
once you drill in a certain place and
and strip our our our natural our
natural resources out of areas sacred
areas in some cases to some individuals
in this country you can't get that back
and we're producing more oil without
having to drill in these places that we
shouldn't be
drilling oh boy oh
boy so and I mean I I mean you know you
can't you can't get these [__] people
to believe the truth because they're so
[__] delusional I mean Jesus Christ
these people are these sheep are
standing in line yelling and screaming
they want Grandpa Hitler to be a
dictator how [__] unamerican is
that now look at this guy okay he's got
a [__] manga hat on he's got his face
painted like Trump does on his avatar on
true
social okay so he's desecrating the
American flag then he's got American
flag pants which by the standards of the
American flag and the code of the flag
this is desecration of the
flag and then he's standing there
wanting Grandpa Hitler to be a a a dict
tasor dictator excuse
me unamerican this guy is not a [__]
Patriot he is unamerican and anyone
still standing in that line after these
people are saying that type of [__] and
supporting Trump are [__]
unamerican you're you're you're not a
patriot you're
not you don't understand what patriotism
is you're not
[__] doing anything but drinking the
[__] dictator Kool-Aid the dictator
Kool-Aid
now there was more dick
tasting um this weekend and I got some
good clips for you uh to show you today
there's several I've got
here here is the here is Granda Hitler
himself this is this clip that everyone
is talking about over the weekend this
one right here now this should not be
surprising that he's talking and he's
he's repeating [__] from mind comp he
had said this blood poisoning [__]
before folks he said it in interviews
before so everyone being surprised I'm
like oh my God oh my God oh what the
[__] no he's been saying this [__] and
he's gonna get
worse this is not going to get
better it is going to get worse and I
mean his rhetoric is going to get worse
be
prepared he's going to go much further
than just repeating a few lines from m
g much
worse he is going to be saying
eventually in the coming months when he
starts winning these primaries he's GNA
start [__] mark my words he's going
to start saying well they want me to be
a
dictator people are saying they want me
to be a dictator on day
one he's going to say that [__] out
loud and they're gonna be like yeah
woohoo people are saying that yes it's
us it's us mindless brainless sheep that
are saying that because we're fascist
and we don't even know what fascist ism
is
yeah worst version of ourselves
yeah it's GNA happen I'm gonna have a
clip and I'm going to tell you at that
moment on December 18th on Monday at
about 12:56 p.m. eastern time I told you
that this was going to
happen hell it might happen before that
that he's standing on stage saying they
want me to be a
dictator so I want to be one and I'm
going to go much further than quoting
minec that whiny little book again just
to reiterate mom means my struggle it
literally was a book that Hitler wrote
whining bitching and moaning while he
was in a prison cell for trying to
overthrow the government that's what it
is and he blamed all his problems on
everyone else but himself [__] sounds
familiar doesn't it why is it so [__]
surprising that this little [__] this
whiny little [__] is quoting from a book
called my
struggle from a whining bitching memoire
of Hitler a murderous [__] dictator
in a prison cell for when he was when he
was in prison for trying to overthrow a
government why is this
surprising it should not be
surprising that this guy this Grandpa
Hitler is embracing
minec but let's listen country when they
do that we got a lot of work to do
they're poisoning the blood of our
country that's what they've done they
poisoned mental institutions and prisons
all over the world not just in South
America not just the three or four
countries that we think about but all
over the world they're okay now he's
gonna he's gonna wind it up here right
because he's like no no no don't just
hate brown people coming across the
border okay don't just hate those brown
folks we got many more folks to hate let
me give you the list of folks we're
supposed to hate and supposed to kill
listen coming into our country from
Africa from Asia all over the world
they're pouring into our country nobody
Africa and Asia
yeah oh
boy I mean what would what would be what
would genocide be without genociding all
the people that you hate huh what would
it be listen you don't like me to say
that it [__] sounds weird and it
sounds really [__] like I'm going way
far out on a limb but folks they're
getting
there they're getting
there little by little by little by
little they're going to tell us what
they actually want I know what they want
I mean if you go listen to the deep deep
dark wed and you just look down in your
comments a little bit they're telling
you what they want they're telling
you they're saying it out loud on social
media and I know you think it's bot
farms and all that [__] trust me there
real [__] fascists Behind These
accounts in some
instances and that's who this [__]
chucklehead is playing to's even looking
at him they just come in the crime is
going to be tremendous the terrorism is
going to be terrorism is going to be and
then we built a tremendous piece of the
wall and then we country just rambling
on and on and on my struggle oh it's my
struggle oh we we did this no one listen
and it it's
all it's those people from Africa and
Asia's fault the people from South made
those brown people coming it's all their
fault it's all their fault that I can't
make a decent [__] wage it's all
their fault that I could go broke
because of a medical
bill it's his struggle right it's his
whiny little [__]
struggle boo [__] who [__]
him and honestly the media being so
surprised that he said this [__]
actually should infuriate you even
more that's right the media being so
[__] surprised like oh my God I can't
believe he's saying this [__] out loud
what get the the [__] out man they are
trying to criminalize pregnancy in
States they are stripping away and
criminalizing Women's Health Care okay
they're criminalizing being being a
member of the lgbtq
community they want to strip away
parental rights from children so they
can tell you how to raise your [__]
children and and they want your children
to get
pregnant oh you [__] doubt me on that
[__] go ahead you [__] try to
doubt me on that
[__] that they don't
want your children to get
pregnant they're saying that [__] out
loud this weekend
too at turning points
USA
continuing
continuing to talk about their [__]
Fascism and their white
replacement oh you don't believe me okay
well I'll show you how they want to take
your parental rights away so they can
get your [__] children pregnant your
little girl's
pregnant here's that greo Charlie Kirk
make sure I me if you're a young person
here and you say boy you know what do I
want to do for my life honestly you
should get married as young as possible
and have as many kids as possible
period you should get married as young
as possible and have as many kids as
possible now I don't know if you know
this I don't know if you know this but
they're Republicans all over the country
all over the country submitting bills
into states trying to pass laws to make
it to where all the way down to 12 girls
can get
married Charlie Kirk knows this this
[__] knows that [__] this
[__] knows that Republicans are
submitting bills all around the country
to try to marry off little girls
children I want you to listen to what
the [__] he says again listen to what he
says again here listen to make sure I
mention if you're a young person here
and you say boy you know what want to do
for my life honestly you should get
married as young as possible and have as
many kids as possible now men can't have
kids Charlie knows
this Charlie knows
this I'm gonna play rants here I'm rat
I'm gonna play your cough Christmas
video just just hang tight I'm gonna
play
it the
audience Charlie knows that there are
Republicans all over the
country trying to pass laws in our
states to marry as as young as 12y old
girls he knows this okay and then this
sick [__] gets on stage saying that they
should get married as young as possible
and have children as young as possible
what he means what he really means is
men should marry girls as young as they
possibly can marry that's what he's
saying and they should make sure they
have as many babies as possible that's
why that's why they they want to take
away parental consent that's why they
want young girls to be forced to have
babies okay that's why they want
12-year-olds to be don't you see
it don't you [__] see it
well let's let's let's let Charlie
explain it here period
reject the siren song of modernity now
some parents are probably oh I I don't
like that you know uh oh oh there you go
parents like oh I don't like that I I
wouldn't give my consent for that wow
what is Charlie think about those
parents and their consent what does he
think about it they should basically you
know they should go get a job first
you're wrong I'm sorry honestly oh
you're wrong you're wrong so that's why
Charlie wants to support Republicans who
are trying to take away P parental
rights and parental consent because
they're doing it
[__] what do you think all the
trans children [__] is what do you think
all that
is when they're talking about trans
Youth and trans
children and going on and on and on and
on and on and on and on and on and on
and
on that is their back door into taking
your [__] parental rights away from
your
children that's what it is they're
demonizing trans children and the
parents of
transen to strip away consent from
parents okay and it starts at parents
just wanting their kid to be who they
are that's where it starts it doesn't
stop just like just like they it starts
at overturning roie Wade it starts there
now in Missouri Mike Moon who by the way
Mike Moon filed a bill so that
12-year-old girls could get married in
Missouri okay he also still has a bill
where it criminalizes women's health
care so much so that at topic
pregnancies would have a class a
felony if you had to have a procedure to
save your life ectopic my wife um um
wanted me to make sure I got the
ectopic I've been saying it wrong I
guess it's probably because I know
nothing about being pregnant so I should
stay the [__] out of it I shouldn't
[__] interject myself between a woman
and her doctor and her health care
that's probably what I should [__] do
because I don't know [__] about it
Charlie Charles you
[__] we are on the verge of a
population collapse in this country
every day I receive emails from young
women oh my God filled with regret in
their late 30s and they say Charlie I'm
sobbing as I write this email because
what you talk about on the show is
exactly right uh Alex I'll take uh
things that never happened for 500
please I'll take things that never
happened for
500 oh my God all right now folks why is
this relevant why is it
relevant because turning points USA gets
funded by the coch brothers and the
Heritage Foundation um they get millions
and millions and millions of dollars to
go to colleges uh they they have they
have High School groups that they try to
develop for turning points USA they're
trying to [__]
brainwash young people into believing
into white Christian nationalism okay
that's that's that's what they're doing
that's what they're trying to do Hitler
Youth Grandpa Hitler Youth is what
they're trying to develop here keep
listening I have a couple college
degrees I have a great job and almost no
debt but I was told you know to forego
having a family but now I'm looking
around and I have a lot of
cats oh my god listen I would put up
with a thousand cats before I'd want
Charlie Kirk to [__] be anywhere near
any woman that I loved anywhere near
them especially anyone who was under the
age of 18 Charles you [__]
weirdo um here's here's U some other guy
I don't know I don't know who this guy
oh this is the guy who's the the founder
of valuetainment someone said that the
other day value
tainment um here on the show or or it
was somewhere they were talking about
valuetainment but here is here's Patrick
Bet David let's see what he has to say
about being pregnant and getting
pregnant this is this whole event like
this whole event is telling young girls
who just are in in college to get
pregnant drop out of college because
it's you know you're a woman and get
pregnant that's your that's your mission
you're a brood may all these Muslims
look how they're growing so fast just 50
years ago we were three times the SI and
now they're the same as us and the next
30 years they're going to be running
Senate and Congress and governors why do
you sound like you're scared oh oh wait
wait this guy is invoking religion he's
invoking Christian Nation or whatever
the [__] that [__] is peanut butter
podcast or whatever the [__] that [__]
oh this is this is the guy from peanut
butter podcast
or whatever F
pbd peanut butter podcast that's this
guy all right now listen listen to what
he says about Muslims and then Christian
nationalism listen listen to what he
says about what we should do because
these people are always like ah great
replacement great replacement they're
trying to replace us listen to this
[__] why don't you go have four five6 S8
babies wh why why do you why do you stop
saying lines like the following where
it's like well you know my h husband and
I we want to spend five years together
and then at 35 years old we'll thinking
about having a kid because you know it's
a lot of work having a kid what do you
think is the biggest juice of life you
think it's a nice house you think it's a
nice car you think it's having a kid oh
my God one of the greatest gifts we have
if you're able to do it with health I
don't want to impose this on some people
who God won't even help you have kids
because you're wanting to have kids
there's so many people I want to have
kids I can but if you can have kids go
four five 5 6 7 8 9 10 go 10
kids that's what they want to look
listen they're like don't let anyone
tell you you don't want to have kids
when you don't want to have kids you
should be forced to have them that's
what they're saying that's what they're
saying I I I don't know if you know this
they're they're saying they're going to
force you to have children okay so keep
voting for Republicans keep doing that
if you want to vote for Republicans keep
doing that and they're going to force
you to have
children all the laws all the
legislation that they're pushing all the
policies that they're
backing they don't want you to have
schooling they don't want you to be
educated [__] they want you to get
married at 12 Mike Moon Senator
Republican senator Mike Moon of the Nazi
party in Missouri is filing bills to
make sure that 12y olds get married and
they want to pass bills to make sure
they have to force 12y olds to have
babies hm I wonder what it could be I
don't know if you know
this but this is some Nazi type [__]
okay this is Nazi type [__] Nazi Germany
and we were talking in the producers
Corner this morning this is real history
you go [__] look it
up at a certain point in Nazi Germany
Hitler started um youth camps he would
start youth camps they'd be like summer
camps you know what I
mean and they'd have the woman's youth
camp or the girls youth camp and the
men's or the boys youth camp at the time
these were teenagers okay these were
teenage youth in Germany and they would
have Summer Camps summer camps but they
were sex camps okay and here here's how
it would kind of work they would put the
women's or the girls camp and the men's
or the boys Camp right next to each
other right and they keep them separated
but they really sex them up you know
what I mean they really sex them up and
you know how teenagers are they're sexed
up anyway you know they got all the
hormones and [__] and they're really
confused and like what is this I'm horny
as [__] you know how teenagers are and
young people are they they start to get
this weird thing that happens to them
you did you you went through it I went
through it we all went through it but
they sex them up a bit in these camps
the Nazis would sex them up and then
then they let them [__] each
other teenagers they let them they were
sex camps and the goal the goal was to
get the the women blonde hair blue eyes
pregnant by the guys that had blonde
hair blue eyes it's a replacement Theory
okay that's why the Wright talks about
the great replacement Theory because the
fash is always
projecting
always when they keep telling us that
Democrats want a replacement theory that
they want brown people and Muslims in
this country so they can replace white
people we're just like no we just they
exist so we figure this is a country for
freedom and liberty and so they should
come here and to the greatest country on
Earth and maybe seek freedom and liberty
I I I mean and maybe when they come here
they'll be voting for freedom and
liberty maybe a party who believes
in in [__] democracy maybe I know
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe maybe I'm
wrong but the Nazis had sex camps now
they're not saying they want to have sex
camps yet and I I make the the caveat
yet because Charlie Kirk is bound to
probably on his [__] show talk about
how he we should have sex camps to our
teenagers girls and boys should be in
camps right next to each other keep them
separated sex them up and then let them
have sex together that way we can create
blondhair blue-eyed white people who can
believe in Christian white
nationalism it's what the [__] they're
saying that's where it's going kids
we're eating dinner tonight come on
Tiffany H Cody Dylan der
Jordan telling
you that's where they're going with
this it may not be a like it right
now that's where they're
headed and they ain't going to stop
there they ain't gonna stop that [__]
listen to this listen listen to Benji
here Benji Johnson listen to this
[__] same
eventa unshakable ladies and gentlemen
let me explain that young men we're just
going to cut right to it if you want
want to be an immovable mountain in your
life if you wish to be a strong Alpha I
beg
you find a
woman fall in love hey uh hey hey Benny
we all know that you're a closeted gay
man we know that I mean we can it's not
hard to see that and really honestly um
I know you're just practicing or
preaching what you practiced where you
found a woman
even though you wanted a man because it
makes you feel more Alpha but it look
being yourself and being truthful with
yourself is way more manly way more
manly it's way more masculine to to be
one with yourself than to pretend to be
something that you're not because most
gay men are way more masculine than
these [__] right-wing basement
dwellers these [__]
keyboard Cowboys that we see all over
the internet I don't know if you guys
know that holy [__] that's right I
speaking speaking of gay
men which I'm not going to avoid this a
lot of lefties are gonna avoid this
there was a a
staffer two two males and they were
having sex in a senate hearing room um
and they filmed it my God why did you
film it that's make evidence of it but
they were having sex in the Senate
hearing room and right-wingers like
Benny Johnson here were posting the gay
porn all over the Internet look Benny
honestly if you guys want to have gay
porn that's fine by me I don't give a
[__] hey whatever floats your boat man
whatever tickles your pickle Benny I
don't give a [__] I could care less
honestly more power to you man if you
find something that you like and it's
consensual and it's legal go for it
let's all have some fun you know what I
mean
I'm all for that whatever you want to do
but
look y'all posted around gay
porn yall post around gay porn all over
the Internet and and images of gay porn
all over the Internet it really does
start to we really start to wonder look
these these Democratic staffers because
they're Democratic staffers that filmed
this thing they were having sex in the C
room yes two and here's how I don't know
if you know this but here's how two gay
dudes have sex they [__] each other in
the butt that's how they that's how gay
dudes normally have sex I don't know if
you know that I don't know if you know
but that's that's porn that's gay porn
but these people of course you know it
just it is what it is that's the type of
porn you
know but these right-wingers they
apparently like that kind of porn they
apparently like it I don't know I mean
and you may a lot of people may like it
I don't know I mean a lot of people
probably watch anal porn I don't I mean
it's possible I may or may not have some
of that in
my in my history I mean Shaz here is
back he's back because we're on
Facebook oh shance you is that a threat
you will make sure never gets
never never gets elected have you ever
been in the Senate hearing room Shaz
with someone filming I don't know I bet
Lindsey Graham
has been in Senate hearing rooms alone
with someone maybe not on camera but I
bet the door was locked this is so
stupid isn't it I know I'm getting off
track here but I can't I can't help but
um get off track with with a closeted
Benny Johnson here he's 100% a gay man
per. I mean that's that's what people
say and I I don't have anything in I
don't I care list Benny here could lock
himself in a room and have gay sex and
film it and put it all over the Internet
for all I give a [__] whatever floats
your boat whatever tickles your pickle
man doesn't make me no difference you
just stop [__] telling other people
they can't be what they want to be okay
and these two Democratic staffers are
gonna be fired right for [__] having
sex in the Senate hearing room but to
act like no one on Capitol Hill has ever
had sex in the Senate hearing room is
really [__] stupid
that's really [__] dumb that you
think people aren't having sex in the
capital offices in the Congressional
offices in the [__] Jesus Christ we
had a president in the 90s who was
getting a
[__] in the Oval
Office people were [__] outraged why
I don't understand it listen if someone
commented on my Twitter if there's a
[__] lock in a room and the door
locks it's likely people are going to
have sex SE in there have had sex in
there are going to try to have sex in
there okay it's called humans we're
humans humans typically they like food
okay they like entertainment and they
love sex like it's a thing it's a thing
that
happens and usually gay gay men have sex
like that like Benny Johnson here
possibly get married have more children
than you can afford what wait go back
what did you say listen mountain in your
life if you wish to be a strong Alpha I
beg you you want to pretend not to be
gay find a woman find a woman cuz that's
number one fall in love Yeah act like
you're in love get married yeah you got
to get married have more children than
you can afford have have more children
than you can
afford oh my god
oh and they think this is a winning
[__]
message what the [__] so what they want
you to do is to believe that if you just
vote for the dictator Grandpa Hitler and
you you want to appear not to be gay you
got to marry a woman act like you're in
love with her uh you definitely you
definitely you definitely want to have
as many a kids so many kids that you
can't afford it that way you rely on the
the [__] fascist regime Wy
[Music]
r
oh my God the [__] is wrong with these
people oh that's right they're Nazis
have insane amounts of kids there's
nothing the world can do to shake you if
you do those simple steps and if you
acknowledge that God loves you and has a
purpose for your life that's it that's
it and you are
immovable they will definitely believe
like people believe that I'm not gay
they definitely believe that you want
you agree with I close it that's that's
what I'm taking from this of course of
course this is all Nazi type [__]
because again
again I don't know how to say
this um maybe I should say it like uh Dr
Rachel boffer said here let me let me
show you what she said about this clip
she says the Nazis were super into birth
rate two both to build up quote the
master race but also to serve and as
eventual Cannon fder for Hitler's murder
machine H in other words if you get
enough people that are born to believe
what you want to believe and you delude
them from a small little age into your
[__] fascist beliefs then you can use
them as a crowd against the others to
make a murder machine that's what these
people are trying to do that's what
they're trying to do and again uh Rachel
doesn't say it here but the the way that
Nazi Germany and Hitler tried to focus
in and really increase the birth
rate was to have teenage sex camps it's
what they
did I I know I know it sounds weird that
a bunch of fascists would be obsessed
with having sex with little teenage
girls I know it sounds
weird does it
but that's what they did in Nazi
Germany now the other thing they did in
Nazi Germany was declare Hitler the
furer and they worshiped him even if
they didn't really want to even they
didn't believe him because if you didn't
worship the furer you would you would
[__] die you would get killed by the
murder machine but there's Steve
Bannon um
begging for a furer listen no person in
the history of this this nation with all
the Patriots we have have ever done what
Trump has done by come back come back to
save his country and the American people
on his side look at the
numbers W there's tens of people
cheering in the crowd
wooo H Grandpa Hitler H Grant Paul
Hitler give me a [__] break those
sons of [__] try to destroy him every
day and he's still
winning he's still
winning yeah it doesn't matter how many
times you say it it doesn't make it true
like Steve listen buddy it doesn't H man
how many times you say it you [__]
human walking
scab it doesn't make it true you can
just lie into a microphone and yell lies
into the
microphone it's not going to make it
true okay it really is
stupid but here's Steve Bon let me play
it again because I don't know if you
know this but this [__] this H this
fixation on a fear her is real listen no
person in the history of this nation
with all the Patriots we have have ever
done what Trump has done by come back
come back to save his country and the
American people on his side look at the
[Applause]
numbers those Sons a [__] try to
destroy him every day and he's still
winning he's still
winning those sons of
[__] I love that Steve Bon thinks I'm
the some [__] oh nothing pleases me
more thanks Steve listen you know you're
on the right side of
history when you're to Steve Bannon
you're a some [__] oh you're you're
you're doing the right thing you're in
the right
Camp you're right
there let me show you some more crazy
[__] here I I'm having trouble with
coughing and I gotta say that um
yesterday we did um Christmas car I'll
get back to some of these clips here but
I got to talk about this for a second I
had a great surprise yesterday
and I I don't get many surprises I'm not
a surprise type person like I don't like
surprises that's why it's probably why
I'm so good at like like hey that's
gonna happen see is because I don't want
to be surprised by it like I'm
constantly thinking what's the worst it
could be and that's the worst it could
be and they're definitely going to be
the worst they can be for sure they're
fascist so like you know that's the
that's the thing like so I'm probably
pretty good at this so I don't like
surprises okay but yesterday I I was
giving a great surprise uh by by our our
my sidekick and our our great laboratory
rat small rat here yeah that that that's
a great elf costume that you got on I
guess you're you're getting ready for
Christmas huh in the laboratory did you
set up a Christmas tree in the
laboratory did you do that did you do oh
okay all right all right well here's the
thing yesterday rat surprised me and I
want to thank you buddy for this great
surprise and I want to show it to the
whole audience because yesterday folks
saw it at the Christmas karaoke but you
know I've had a bit of
the
cough here the last couple weeks and rat
made me a special um Christmas video and
I want to show all of you this video
right
[Music]
now jingle bells jingle bells Tony's got
to cough can't seem to shake it off it's
really getting love sitting hot coco by
for Christmas tree but all I hear is
Tony cing can't you see cing cing he
just won't
stop Tony's got a cough and it's going
nonstop
jingle bells jingle bells mixed with
cing sounds but we rock theid spread all
around jingling through the
night all right thank you very much for
the surprise rat I really like that song
um it's very nice I know the audience
likes it too so thank you very much yes
yes Merry Christmas to you too buddy and
happy holidays speaking of that I want
to tell everyone while I've got you here
Rand I want to tell everyone about the
schedule coming up over the next couple
weeks the holiday schedule so um this
weekend is Christmas well kind of
Christmasy um so we're gonna be we're
gonna be doing a show today tomorrow and
Wednesday we will be off Thursday Friday
Monday and Tuesday so we're going to
have a long weekend
okay and then we will come back next
week on Wednesday and Thursday and
Friday and the next week is New Year's
so we will take the same two days off
and we will come back on that next
Wednesday Thursday Friday so the next
three weeks because of how the holiday
falls we have three three day weeks and
then when we come back we'll really be
after the shart Army and really smashing
the fascist every single week day for
two full hours but but the next three
weeks will be our holiday schedule are
you ready for Christmas rat did you get
any have you got your Christmas shopping
done have you done your oh okay well
that's good that's good it's it sounds
like you you're ready then you're ready
for this um this holiday season are you
ready are you are you gonna get drunk on
the break are you gonna yeah okay well I
figured you'd be getting drunk you like
eggnog oh well you know I'm just asking
I'm just as some people like I don't I
don't like eggnog but some of you might
like eggnog all right everybody I I
again I appreciate this special surprise
yesterday I did not see that coming and
it was a great surprise and I really
appreciate your hard work on the
Christmas song and I'll try to work hard
on over the holidays of getting rid of
my cough so thank you buddy all right
all right get back in a laboratory go go
make some sounds and some AI images go
play with the AI a little
bit all right all right let's get back
to some of these
clips oh let's see that I want to show
that one but there's more important ones
I think than that one
um that yeah that's one oh yes here this
might work out good remember I was
saying Mike
Moon uh this is the guy who try who has
a bill
Missouri criminalizing pregnancy for
women certain pregnancies uh and trying
to ban Women's Healthcare and
criminalize women Healthcare he's he's a
senator he's of the Republican Nazi
party in Missouri his name is Mike Moon
um and he's the one who wants to marry
off 12-y old girls listen as I
contemplated the bill I was reminded of
a couple I'd met years before when this
couple was in their teens actually
pre-teens
they took actions that resulted in the
girl becoming pregnant the youngsters
parents decided to allow the children to
marry they weren't forced however oh
they weren't they weren't they weren't
forced it's not like you can force uh
preens to get married or
anything this is what the [__]
turning points USA their entire thing
was
about now I don't know if you remember
this this is a clip from Mike moon in
the last legislative session in Missouri
where he introduced a bill to to let 12y
olds get married 12-year-old girls get
married now these he keeps saying that
it's a a pre-teen couple what he really
means is he wants grown ass men to marry
little girls that's what the [__] they
mean that's what the [__] they mean they
don't want men to get married when
they're pre-teens or teenagers Jesus
Christ what what what the [__] no they
want men to be educated they want men to
go to College they want men to have
careers and they want the women at home
so they can breed them and have more
children than they can afford that's
what [__] Benny Johnson says right
just listen to what they're saying and
you'll know their
ideology but Mike Moon had to make this
video to explain away why he wants grown
ass men to marry [__] 12-year-old
girls keep going Mike keep digging this
video by the way um this video
is not recent this is from April this
year this is from April okay but Mike
moon now has a bill where he wants to
criminalize Women's Health Care in the
state of Missouri he's the same one
filed this bill but listen to his
explanation because they were not mature
and could not provide for themselves
they grew up with their families in
different states after a number of years
when the children became adults and were
able to care for themselves they began
to living together the couple is still
married today so with this in mind and
because allowances for these extreme
exceptions were not included in the
language I voted against the
bill tragic circumstances such as these
can only be overcome through one Avenue
the grace and mercy of God in the word
of the Lord Romans 3:23 States for all a
sin and come short of the glory of God
this couple like me have a sin nature
the Bible goes on to say in Romans 623
all right all right right I can't stand
the white Christian nationalism and
using their religion to justify [__]
Maring off little girls to grown assmen
I can't do it and to justify that they
want these little girls to be brood
mares for the state where they just
produce more children than they can
[__] afford this is [__] just
brain dead [__] this is [__]
ridiculous and honestly if if you are on
the side of these stupid [__]
you are on the wrong side of History
you're going to get squashed in this
election like it's not going to go
[__] well for you it's just
not it's not you just need to get to the
[__] truth get to it have it hold it
go for it stop [__] trying to control
other [__] stop it stop it and
pick out something you believe and
believe it okay listen I've been how
long has the band been wait it's it's
it's been it's been a
week we've been banned for a week now
we've been banned from Facebook for
longer okay it was a 30-day ban from
Facebook I don't know if you remember 30
days ago or not but I remember 30 days
ago I can REM I was I can remember that
far
back I can remember back how I can
remember 60 days ago I can remember I
can remember a year ago
oh [__] it's a it's a wild thing the
memory the human memory the human brain
does some wild
[__] but I remember just 30 days ago our
favorite
troll on
Facebook oh man he was getting in the
comments he loved Ronda santis Ronda
santis is Gonna Save this country he was
going to get rid of the gays he's going
to do all kinds of crazy [__] this Ron s
he was going to be a great fascist and
then between the time we got baned and
now someone said I want to be a dictator
and it looks like our favorite troll has
abandoned his Florida
fascist for King
manga Shazier says Ronda santis will
never be president can I get an amen
Shaz I was telling you that man okay I
was I was I was saying that and you were
saying that you wanted Ronda santis to
be I'm so glad we're back on Facebook by
the way
this is this is gonna be so
fun Shaz you are a dumb son of a [__]
man you know that I record this show
right you do know that this [__] is
recorded right you do know that the
internet lives
forever like
forever you know that your comments are
still in those [__] show comments you
know that
[Laughter]
right this is why I said you are a
stupid [__] and you are gonna
regret coming here and commenting on my
show you're gonna regret this
[__] what what happened did the santis
because they ran out of money and staff
did they did they have to stop paying
you did you have to flip to the Trump
campaign to get paid to come comment on
shows is that what
happened I mean I don't know I'm I'm
asking just I'm just asking questions
because he said I listen to Ronda santis
town hall and this guy's worse than jeed
bush
dude he's saying he's saying the same
[__] and wearing the same high heels he
was wearing a month
ago you're the same [__] that
told me I couldn't make fun of Ronda
santz do you see how big of a [__]
joke you are I don't I'm just trying to
point it out to you because this is
gonna be the life of all manga this is
gonna be your life we're just going to
keep pointing out how ridiculous you are
that you have no principles you have no
grounding principles and the reason why
is because you're running from
something you're running from something
Chez why is the santis a
bobblehead why why are you we we all
[__] know Ronda Sanz is a [__] box
man we all know he's a [__]
box now we like to mock him because he's
weird
right and he's really [__] awkward
he's kind of like a humanoid kind of
like
you but now you're against him what's
happened in the last 30 days
Chez what happened my
man what
happened I'm glad you agree say d santis
is weird hey
Shaz Grandpa Hitler Donald
Trump he's a fascist he wants to be a
dictator
he'll kill
you if you stand in his way if you
descent against Grandpa Hitler like
you're descenting against Ronda santis
right now do you have any idea what your
fate will
be huh do you have any idea have I
talked some senson to you is this what
this
is is this what this
is
huh have I finally talk some sense into
youz will you support Joe Biden to save
democracy to make
sure that when you desent that you're
not off to a camp
huh oh nothing pleases me more he says
if Trump loses or if Nikki Haley can't
be the nominee I'm leaving
[Laughter]
America I look listen look if Trump wins
you better leave America
man because you're going to be known as
a denter you know that right because you
said one thing in the chat and then you
said another when they start to come
around and look at your social media
because they're going to do that man if
they take over they're definitely gonna
look at your [__] social media and
see that you're a denter against
fascist you're [__] dude you're [__]
you think they're going to let the
you think they're going to let descent
in their
party you think they're just going to
Breeze over the fact that you used to
support one person now you're supporting
someone else and that you're saying that
you would support Nikki
Haley oh you're saying you're saying if
Nikki Haley becomes the nominee oh yeah
so so oh I I oh okay so I get it you you
did come here and listen now I see
what's happening you came here and
listened right came here and
listened to what I was saying and you
decided that you needed to get on the
Trump train because if you weren't you
might be dead at the dictator you're
like whoa he wants to be a dictator he
wants to be gra Paul Hitler whoa [__] I
better not descent against him because
he'll kill me I'm glad you're listening
honestly I'm glad you're listening
because i' I've told I've told my
friends this who have jokingly said
they're going to vote for for RFK Jr
instead of Biden and I told them I said
look don't vote for RFK Jr instead of
Biden vote for Trump okay if you're
gonna vote for Trump to
win if you're gonna vote for Trump to
win please vote for Trump because when
they get to the voting roles because
these fascists will go to the voting
roles to see who you voted for because
they're going to get rid of Elections
see they're going to get rid of
Elections all right they're totally
going to get rid of election
and then they're going to come around to
see who voted in the final
election and anyone who didn't vote for
Trump is going to be on the chomping
block so I'm glad you finally came
around to a realization that Trump wants
to be a dictator and for you to be part
of the fash that you got to get on the
fast train and you got to support the
dict taster Grappa
Hitler you're such a [__] bonehead
man I'm so glad to be back on Facebook
where I can see your boneheaded
it's [__] great it's [__] great
and you're going to have to buy we're
all going to have to crowd fund for
shaz's plane ticket and his at the price
of his
uh of his
passport maybe get him a hotel
somewhere because if Trump loses the
election or something happens to him I'm
leaving America okay man okay that
sounds that sounds like you're
worshiping an CU eventually Trump's not
Immortal
man oh my God Shaz hey Shaz and take a
look at this you'll love this video this
is against your your sacred moms for
Liberty this was Aunt Bridget Ziggler
you guys know who Bridget Ziggler is
she's the head of the Min
[__] yeah she's the one her and her
husband were [__] other women loving
gay sex loving oh they love gay sex they
do but they hate when other people like
it so again it's rules for thee not for
me right that's how fascism Works uh but
this guy puts bridet Ziggler in her
place at the um Schoolboard meeting
listen to this this is [__] fantastic
Bridget our first ever interaction was
when you retweeted a hate article about
me from the Nationalist while I was a
sarasa county school
student you are a reminder that some
people view Politics as a service to
others while some view it as an
opportunity for themselves on this board
you have spent public funds that could
have been used to increase teacher pay
to change our district lines for
political gain remove books from schools
Target Trans in queer children erase
black history and elevate your political
career all while sending your children
to private schools because you do not
believe in the public school system that
you've been
leading my question is why doesn't an
elected official using our money to harm
our students and our teachers for her
gain seem to matter as much to us as her
having a threesome
does Bridget Zigler you do not deserve
to be on the Sarasota County School
Board but you do not deserve to be
removed from it for having a threesome
that defeats the lesson we've been
trying to teach you which is that a
politician's job is to serve their
Community not to police personal lives
so to be extra clear Bridget you deserve
to be fired from your job because you
are terrible at your
job not because you had sex with a
woman oh
baby and chz oh boy you did exactly what
I wanted you to do you dumb
[__] you're so predictable I'm
so glad to be back on Facebook moms for
Liberty is a patriotic group they're
hardworking moms how do you feel about
them being an lgbtq group huh chance huh
how about how do you feel about them
having sex with each other them women
having gay sex with each other huh how
do you feel about that that that moms
for Liberty the man [__] are a secret
LGBT group how do you feel about that
buddy all right all right that's a
[__] fantastic video by the way it's
a great video
fantastic he is a great job because
that's the truth like like the whole the
whole Lauren bobert thing where she was
jacking off the guy in the theater like
really honestly I didn't I didn't think
the reason why she shouldn't be a
congress person was because she was
jacking off some dude in a theater in
the beetle juu uh rendition theatrical
rendition I really didn't think that was
the reason why she should not be a
congress person there's so many more
[__] reasons before that of why she
should not be in
Congress one of which does not include
hand jobs okay the same thing goes with
this [__] um this staffer of Ben
cardens who was is fired gone okay
they're
gone it's not a thing they're gone
they're fired all right but yeah gay
dudes when they have sex and they film
it it's it's gay sex that's that's what
it is when when heterosexual people have
sex and they film it it's it's it's
heterosexual sex if there's three people
having sex like Bridget Ziggler and her
husband Christian and and the other
woman and they're having sex and
Bridget's having sex with the woman why
her husband's having sex with him it's
it's it's also that's that's that's kind
of gay it's kind of heterosexual and
homosexual at the same time I don't know
if you know that it's kind of weird how
people can't just [__] figure [__]
out
easily um but I want to show you a video
because um I've Unearthed this video
here of the rightwing including Shaz and
the shart Army um watching this is this
is live footage of them watching and um
continuing to play the staffer gay sex
in the Senate hearing room on their
timelines watch
[Music]
here
that's all I can think of when I when I
think of the rightwing and Chaz and The
Shard Army um watching the uh staffer
the gay sex
staffers filming themselves in the
Senate hearing room that's what I see I
I can't help it I can't help it what do
you want from
me you know most of these lefties are
not gonna cover the that gay gay sex
hearing room story most are not they're
gonna like oh you shouldn't really talk
about that Tony shouldn't really talk
about that that that hurts Democrats oh
boy oh boy oh boy get the [__] out of
here what are you talking about again
they're having sex okay they're having
sex now I'm G to I'm going to show this
to you now this is this is a censored
one because I can't show the one that
that the entire shart Army is um
spreading around Twitter because it
actually shows the two dudes having sex
and if you're into that you can go find
the video if you're into that kind of
thing what whatever you want to do I
mean it was consensual it's obvious in
the video that the gay sex was
consensual and again if you're not aware
of
two gay dudes normally have sex you
might be surprised but you can go
watch the
video I'm getting all getting all choked
up oh boy oh
boy but here's Jack prostate um I they
they C they couldn't help themselves
over the weekend this is Jack prostate
he's posting this on Twitter okay now
this is is one of the images um yes this
is this is an actual screenshot from the
video that they film you can see this is
the Senate hearing room that these two
staffers were having sex in um and of
course they they are gay men so that
this is how gay men have sex so it's not
surprising all right but apparently they
love it um because Jack here is posting
pictures all around the internet about
this y'all love sharing gay porn and
Hunter hog piics Wonder what it could be
that's what I ask Jackie never responded
though of course he didn't
[Laughter]
respond remember remember when they
they're they're really upset just last
week about heterosexual sex between
between Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce
they were really upset oh my God they
were so
upset dedis says I wasn't
ready I wasn't going to warn you that I
was going to show you censored pictures
of these Democratic um Senate staffers
having sex in the
um in the CER here hey hey Shaz you're
like hey what's that that's a Democrat
right there hey hey buddy hey buddy I I
hate I hate to break it to you um but
there's a ton of Republicans in in in
Washington DC they're closeted and they
love to have gay sex um just just go
look up just go look up lady G um
Lindsey Graham has probably likely had
sex and the type of sex that he likes in
a senate hearing room okay it's probably
likely I mean I'm not saying it's a it's
a guaranteed thing but it's it's
probably likely okay this this whole
[__] we run away from sexuality and
[__] in this country is so stupid we
make sex and all this [__] taboo which I
mean you should not be having sex in a
senate hearing room you shouldn't be
doing that all right it's not a thing if
you want to keep your job
if you want to keep your job you
probably shouldn't be doing that and
especially filming it okay if you're
going to have sex in a place that you
shouldn't have sex in you probably
shouldn't be filming it it's probably
not a thing you should be doing like
have proof of the thing that you're not
supposed to be
doing but if you believe that there
isn't
[__] that Lindsey Graham hasn't
participated and this type of
[__]
okay then you're not paying the [__]
attention hang on a second hang on a
second I'm got to check something
here oh okay good I'm just making sure
all right your Tweet sucks to Jack sucks
hard
Jack I think Jack would like for it to
suck hard I don't know I'm just saying
I'm very secure about my sexuality I can
I can go um look at look at what
happened over the weekend
um I'm I'm very secure I can go look at
what happened over the weekend and see
oh yeah that's that's gay sex they were
having gay sex in the Senate room they
should probably be fired for that and be
objective about it rightwing cannot be
objective they can't stop watching the
video you know what I mean they can't
stop watching the [__] video of it
but that's not surprising let me see if
um see if I I don't know if Gabe's going
to have a episode he was considering
having an episode today he usually is on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday let me check
in with him real quick I need to see uh
yeah um um um Roland points out a good
uh has a good point there there's some
news about Matt schlap remember I um we
were doing a video and and um they were
talking about someone going to someone's
house and then they're like oh we're all
gonna go to the slap's house for
Christmas I like what is it
what
huh um so Matt schlap apparently
uh was
a has two more sexual harassment
allegations assault allegations and
they're not on women they're they're on
men um which again I you know you
shouldn't be sexually assaulting people
no matter how you what your sexual
preference is you shouldn't be sexually
assaulting people Matt I mean maybe it'd
be better for you if you just you know
told the truth and be yourself but I
know you can't be because you're you
know part of the fascist party and
they'll send you off to a camp speaking
of sending people off to a camp I want
to show you I want to show you one more
godd damn it I want to show you one more
clip of Grandpa poopy pants Grandpa
Hitler here um talking about how he
wants to have um an SS it's the Trump SS
is what he's talking about speaking to
sending people off the camps um that's
what he's talking about here in this um
in this clip because he's talking about
law enforcement and he does this weird
dance um with law enforcement and how he
wants to get inm indemnify them and he's
he's talking about starting a trump SS
he's trying to get law enforcement and
he's fascist in law enforcement in the
military to support him and then he'll
indemnify them if he just if they just
do what he says and send people off to
can listen to
this we will restore Law and Order to
our community communities and I will
direct a completely overhaul doj to
investigate every radical out of control
fake crooked prosecutor in America for
their illegal racist in Reverse
enforcement of the law so anyone who
dissents he'll get rid of them he'll
send them to GMO and you know whatever
he's going to do all right let's listen
to how you want to do
it I am also going to indemnify all
police officers this is a big thing and
it's a brand new thing and I think it's
so important it's not a brand new thing
man it's not a brand new thing this is
not new you're not creating you're not
being creative here you're just living
by the [__]
fash [__] game plan okay this is not
new this is not unique you just said
that you want to get rid of all
dissidents that are in the judicial
system and then you're like how I'll do
it is I'll I'll I'll get long law
enforcement to do it for me I'm going to
indemnify through the federal government
all police officers and law enforcement
officials throughout the United States
from being destroyed by the radical left
for taking strong actions against Crime
oh I see so what you want to do is you
want to use law enforcement to round up
the judges and kill
them oh that's what you want to do oh H
sounds familiar anyone who dissents and
wants to hold you accountable you want
to
indemnify the law enforcement give them
some sh patches because that's what they
are it's SS he's talking about the Trump
SS the Trump Nazi SS folks that's what
he's talking about and he's gonna Round
Up judges and dissident and he's going
to indemnify those people and give them
immunity from all the crimes that
they're going to commit against us you
stupid [__] wake up wake up wake up W
up wake up pluck your head out of your
[__] ass Shaz and the shart Army
pluck your head out of your [__]
ass we're talking about Nazis here dumb
[__] I didn't want to go without playing
that clip because the two clips that are
not surprising and the two clips that
because a lot of people are playing
other clips about this
[__] and I wonder when he's going to do
the indemnification that he's talking
about because there is no there is no
mechanism that allows him to do that I
don't know if you know that there's no
mechanism that allows the president of
United States to do that to give full
immunity to law
enforcement it's not a thing that exists
oh that's right he's probably going to
do it on day one when he becomes the
dictator except for day one you [__]
boneheads Jesus [__] Christ here's
the good news about this okay let me
show you let me show you the good
news this is a video and Maga is posting
this video all over [__] the internet
and this is them bragging about how big
the rally was I'm not [__] you this
is the good news there ain't that many
of them listen listen to the video this
is in New Hampshire this is at the big
rally where he talks about the Trump
Nazi SS and blood poisoning and he's
going to round up people and and D defy
give immunity to law enforcement to do
his bidding listen to the crowd here how
pathetic it
[Music]
[Applause]
is we we want
Trump
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they kind of faded off they they they
only had about 101 15 in them you know
what I mean there's only about 10 or 15
we want trumps in them and you know it's
like I don't know couple hundred
people he filled up a middle school gym
I'm not kidding you before we go I'm
running out of time U by the way Gabe
sanchezz is not going to have a today um
so you're going to have to find
something else to do after the show here
maybe go watch more videos of on my
YouTube channel now it we're not banned
anymore here's
another here's another [__] video
that they're bragging about this these
videos are Maga posting this on the
internet they're bragging about it
here's the video inside inside the
middle school gymnasium that they filled
halfway
watch
oh my God look at look at the tens of
people look at the tens of people oh my
God look at that look at the tens of
people now I I want to tell you this
this stadium that they're in is is it's
a small University I think and this
Stadium holds
7,000 okay I don't know if you noticed
but they cut it in half okay that's what
they do with stadiums a lot when they're
having big events like this they cut it
in half
so this this venue holds
7,000 but they cut it in half
okay cut it in
half so it's only half as much that
could be in
there so they barely they barely got
3,000 people in this Stadium
okay and they're trying to convince us
that he's popular oh my God and they're
posting it all the look look at the
massive
crowd he look could fill a middle school
gymnasium and we're supposed to [__]
believe that he's popular that he's the
most popular person that's ever walked
the face of the Earth that he's the most
popular president of all time that no
one pales in comparison of how much
people love him give me a [__] break
that is the biggest lie that we have
ever been [__]
told that he's
popular the big that's the big lie that
is the big [__] lie
folks that he's
popular let me show you because here's
another one video that really [__] the
bed at the Trump rally mon what do you
what do you think about all of the
attacks coming against Donald Trump uh I
think all the politicians are all crap
including Donald Trump what do
you even all the people at
the even all the people at the rally do
not support him oh my
God oh my God that's [__] fantastic I
am so glad to be back on this Monday I'm
so glad to be back on Facebook I'm so
glad to be back on YouTube and we're
here on Twitch and the new place
Instagram if you're watching from
Instagram oh baby you're on Instagram I
also want to welcome back Kevin Kevin
Craft um to the chat um he's been away
for a while with health issues so I want
to welcome him back thank you thank you
for for coming back and joining the [__]
them fam again we hope you we hope that
you uh continue to come back and
participate in the chat and you remain
in the [__] them fam as always to you
it's the holiday week so I'm probably
going to say Merry Christmas and happy
holiday several times so if I offend you
by saying Merry
Christmas we don't get a does anyone
really get offended by merry I've never
been offended by someone telling me
Merry Christmas never never ever ever
all right folks I got one more
announcement before we leave one more
one more announcement
tonight I Yours Truly the Tony Michaels
will be on Hal Sparks evening show I I
think it's at 6 Eastern is when I'm
supposed to go on I believe so I need to
check my time I need to check my time
but I am going on H Sparks show I'm
gonna go on Hal spark show that's right
I've been invited to be on h spark show
tonight at 6 Eastern I believe that's
when I'm on so go check me out tonight
on Hell spark show uh and I'm sure you
can find hell's stuff anywhere you want
so we'll be doing that tonight as well
uh I appreciate you joining me as we
come back to YouTube as we come back
back to Facebook all in the same day and
we drop on Instagram and of course we're
in twitch I appreciate all your support
while I was being brand B while I was
suspended and banned from Facebook and
YouTube you guys are awesome the [__]
fans awesome the mod squad's awesome rat
small rat with the cough video [__]
greatest eating dinner tonight greatest
Christmas present ever again we will be
off Thursday Friday this week but we're
back tomorrow and
Wednesday same time same place Merry
Christmas Surfs Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
all boys aren't
blue and I will quote from
it I put some lube on and got him on his
knees and I began to slide into him from
behind I pulled out of him and kissed
him while he
masturbated he asked me to turn over
while he slipped a condom on himself
this was my ass and I was struggling to
imagine someone inside
me he got on top and slowly inserted
himself into me it was the worst pain I
think I have ever felt in my life
eventually I felt a mix of pleasure with
the pain close
quote
that